li pratta connaît bien tous les jours
l'animateur installe son camion tout est
préparé dans les moindres détails
vérifie que le camion soit deux niveaux
pour le maître de niveau de façon à ce
que quand les jeunes vont jouer au baby
foot n'est pas une équipe avantagés par
rapport à l'autre son camion cadeaux
s'arrête dans des communes reculées du
département pendant les vacances et dans
deux collèges en période scolaire
matteo 12 ans est un habitué voilà cours
on s'ennuie un peu donc quand il vient
c'est ça tue un peu long nous à
l'origine de l'initiative un constat les
communes du nord-ouest de l'indre et
loire sont des points de vue de lieu
d'accueil pour les jeunes alors il ya un
an
ces communes ont décidé de créer un
local ambulants pour venir alors je
pense qu'on est sur un territoire qui
dans le domaine des ados comme dans
d'autres domaines a été peut-être un
petit peu oubliée pendant pendant un
certain nombre d'années et là enfin il
ya quelque chose qui commence à bouger
il ya quelque chose qui amène un plus
pour les ados mais donc pour la
population il ya beaucoup de parents
aussi qui passe au camion et qui trouve
le concept très intéressant très
intelligent et en tout cas ça permet à
leurs enfants d'avoir un lieu où ils
puissent se retrouver ils puissent
occuper et puis ce beau ça y est il va
perdre c'est de ma faute
exactement aux initiatives à succès qui
pourrait inspirer d'autres communes